recently I concentrated a lot on sports
and on the workout and how to be healthy
because I'm really against plastic
surgeries people can be pretty and
healthy by working on themselves and
eating properly versus just going to the
surgeon people are buggy in 2018 for
instance only in America they are there
are 257 million people who have a
smartphone and out of these people 80%
of people are in social media any one of
these 80% can actually become an
Instagram model and I think that really
very a very very small portion of people
can become a fashion model this is
completely different because if you take
away the makeup if you take away the
filters if you take away maybe the
plastic surgery and all the retouching
see what is really at the end I wouldn't
necessarily agree with that and I can
say why the thing is we don't treat as
photos that much anymore because we do
body positivity and we're out industry
has moved a lot away from what it used
to be oh the filter oh editing if
anything the influencers nowadays we're
trying to break that down we're trying
to break down the filters we're trying
to break down you know hiding behind
facetune and photoshopping and whatever
[ __ ] that you know we got on our phones
these days it's starting to become more
raw that's why I think that we're on the
front line to you know where we're
posting all our flaws and every little
role in stretch mark and everything and
it's for people to judge I'm pretty sure
at least two of them have had a lot of
plastic surgery it's possible but what
is it change I always also just think
it's kind of weird to be piloting
positivity body positivity doctor
changed my body yeah I know that's weird
to me it's a girl girl I Instagram just
like full of surgeries which is fine
fine
you're not dunking that it's just that
she wrote accepting myself click I'm
like ashtag accepting yourself now
I recently I concentrate the light on
sports and on the workout and how to be
healthy because I'm really against
plastic surgeries and I'm trying to
emphasize a lot that people can be
pretty and healthy by working on
themselves and eating properly versus
just going to the surgeon they got a
seven kill streak and call duty called
in an air strike - what did I just see
talking and I was looking at her upper
lip not moving I was like the thing is
you can have had plastic surgery and not
be for it anymore don't look at me like
I ain't even a part of this listen I
don't care that these Instagram models
do what they do I'm just like sick and
tired of being people win full of [ __ ]
if you had plastic surgery it's okay but
don't preach to everybody that they
should love themselves as they are when
you weren't able to do it and you paid
thousands of dollars to have a doctor
cut you up and fix you the way that you
wanted now now that you've done it now
you're preaching if mmm it's like
preachers who say no homo and homo three
years ago in this like not a fake story
actually like my knuckle my nose is
still crooked um I broke her nose like
three years ago and I had to get my nose
done and I did remove the bump because
you already paying for it so might as
well I'm sure that made you happy it
made me very happy like I honestly was
insecure about my bump
I was getting a lot of not you know not
the good compliments necessarily about
it I loved it but still people were like
you know and yeah it made me very happy
I still couldn't fix the whole thing but
what did you do breast augmentation okay
yeah I mean it's just an enhancement it
was something that was gonna make me
happier so I just did it from I'm a huge
problem with what they're seeing if
you're telling people to love themselves
as they are and you're then afterwards
saying I became happy because of what I
did what I said that doesn't make any
sense if you're saying cosmetic surgery
is what made you happy then you are
preaching something to people that is
unhealthy if your self-esteem is based
off whether or not you get a cosmetic
surgery you have a poor basis for us or
self-esteem it's the equivalent of
preaching veganism while eating a turkey
sandwich animal cruelty if you have
plastic surgery and you preach abstract
living yourself change that it's loving
yourself now we're gifted with our
genetics like Asian still reasons but
like when it comes to our body like we
need to put in either like the finance
or like the work in it I had like the
tiniest funny nose when I was little and
I was oh my god like I didn't like my
nose you know it was weird shaped and
and when I grew up being a model then
the photographer's were like oh my god
we love you nose I was like oh my nose
okay and it really taught me to accept
it and I love it now I'm so glad you
know I never thought about doing any
surgery or my nose or anything but you
know he taught me to love myself the way
I am so know that I've had like a
similar experience I'm half Japanese so
I wasn't really no blessed that it
curves but and I used to not like that I
used to be like oh when people see me
you know I don't like a track if I don't
have boobs they don't have a butt but as
soon as I got onto the modeling world
they're like oh no that's a good thing
it's good to be flattered I was like oh
okay now I have something
my job is inclusive of all races gender
sexuality when I was growing up I was
never thinking that I can be a model
because I was never at the model n type
now I'm represented by an agency I work
with a worldwide brand I could never
think that that would ever happen to me
and I'm so grateful it's not inclusive
all body types because generally the
things that I'm wearing are not made
from all body types so in order to do my
job I have to maintain a certain you
know form you know a certain shape for
runway models what these designers are
creating our sample sizes and you have
to be able to fit into this sample sizes
so that's mostly why it's not as
inclusive of body type I guess but I
definitely do believe that the modeling
industry is becoming more diverse yeah
especially like nowadays I would love to
say that you know the modeling industry
includes everybody
it does include races and everyone but
it's true when we talk about body type
people have to be a certain height and a
certain you know she's body shape to be
able to do it is like comparing someone
who plays tennis and plays for fun and
someone who plays professionally and
actually train for years for that as
well like a Roger Federer and not
everyone gets to be him house a low-key
this he's basically saying people that
you guys are just doing this you know
people that don't have real jobs you
know professional like myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow
all right well there cannot consistence
with reviews there some people are not
consistent with youth I mean that's
exactly what it is hey bro don't what I
mean
don't preach the Word of God if you
don't follow it amen
you guys think guys who I read Jewish
well then if you didn't preach I'd be
like change your name [ __ ] like you
said and when you're in magazines you
know I've seen my pictures on econ and
their thighs are smooth there's no
cellulite and you know what that sells
the clothes it gets things done
it's what the customers want to see and
I'm perfectly okay with that what
happened I don't say what happened to
the idea that you want the sound image
that was attainable for everyone oh no
now cuz it sells forget my morals and my
values because it's I just y'all man
people gotta be more consistent this is
very disappointing
yeah very disappointing because I had a
negative impression of its to Instagram
models for my personal experiences of
what I've seen online and this just made
it worse I'm not cool with it like have
you two never been photoshopped like
nobody has ever retouched your photos in
no way the question is are we okay with
it that's a different question but
because you know I'm not saying I'll be
honest I'm not saying I'm never
retouching my photos yes but it does not
make it okay I think when it comes to
retouching I don't have control of the
image I do the job and then they have
control of that image so that's one
thing like I if it were to me I would
like to be as natural book natural as
possible because I want I'm a human and
so I have flaws and I'm thankful for the
way I look but I'm not perfect and so
I'd like to represent myself like I'd
like to be this is Who I am
and sometimes I'll look and like see
these filters and people look like alien
but low key because you can tell us the
difference in levels and tellings ain't
that crazy that the most body positivity
person is actually the runway models
yeah well he's saying he said yes flaws
but everyone's like non-league you look
perfect right but even him he except
would you refuse a job if you would know
they can now Photoshop the hell out of
you if they're gonna Photoshop the hell
out of me then I'm not doing the job
essentialy
yeah like it's not it's not me then you
might as well get anything it's like my
photo looks good and I don't look like
too hourglass like I'm fine with it but
how do you decide if you're okay with it
then you're okay with them doing
whatever they want
I get to have my own photographer makeup
artists and my photographer at is my
photos so we can always collaborate on
like reshaping and stuff so it's not
like a magazine my personal opinion when
it comes to especially Instagram models
I'm like Nia no that's a no for me one
because they promote lifestyles that
aren't reasonable that aren't real that
are completely faked you know the
difference between Dettman models like
models are on the runway you know what I
mean like went up and also the culture
for models at least from what I've
personally seen hasn't been as pervasive
as how social media influencers are in
everybody's phones am I wrong
I think you're right on that right so
when I see with the influence that they
have and how people were like no
followers are trying to build their
empire and how they're trying to mimic
stuff and how they're it's like they've
created this lifestyle around their work
where their life is beholding to their
work and the work is not beholden to
their life does that make sense
meaning our work is based off our lives
our lives is not based on our work that
make sense yeah yeah and also the fact
that we don't do the same thing because
yeah but you guys are on internet do
yeah but you don't know that much about
my life we do puzzles or commentaries
and that's pretty much it
we don't showcase you how lavish our
lives is because it's not we broke but
even if it was I wouldn't promote I
wouldn't that's not what this is about
it's none of your business
well I know you can't compare what we do
to what Instagram I know I'm doing this
not exactly where I'm saying yes not and
I don't think anyone's gonna try to make
that argument with us but you know some
people would read them sometimes letting
me dunk when it comes to Instagram Marlo
specifically as a result of what kind of
life they believe I portray as being
real then other people sit at home and
then they try to emulate
lifestyle it's not real its crunchy its
cringy everyone's trying to act like
they pop in bottles and doing all this
dumb nonsense I'm like it's embarrassing
because I'm like you're sacrificing your
real life to put free something online
for likes so all this to say I mean it
just didn't give me a better opinion of
people that I already had a bad opinion
of and yeah that was crazy as [ __ ] this
is why I don't follow Instagram models
online nope
not gonna feed into this garbage but
anyways maybe we're seeing it
incorrectly want to hear your comments
below what do you guys think do you guys
think that Instagram models represent it
very well what about the runway models
to us know what you think
[Music]